e molto importante conoscere il mio
lavoro per capire questo intervento e
vediamo qual è il lavoro del naso
il naso è una persona che ha a
disposizione una grandissimo al fatto
teca con materie prime a volte naturali
a volte di sintesi che miscela di volta
in volta per creare delle fragranze
ispirate ad un qualche evento ma una
persona oppure ad un brief specifico
dato dal dal committente e vediamo come
funziona la memoria la memoria infatti
va è la più forte che noi abbiamo
risiede nel nella parte più antica del
nostro cervello e della sede esattamente
come
la fame sonno la sete il sesso è un
istinto per cui non viene mediato dal
cervello l'olfatto e ognuno di noi
estremamente libero di provare emozioni
quando annusa per la prima volta una
fragranza l'olfatto fa parte della
nostra esistenza dal primo giorno
all'ultimo vedremo due immagini che ci
colpiranno moltissimo il bambino
sviluppa il primo rapporto con la mamma
proprio attraverso l'olfatto non è la
vista non è il gusto ma è proprio
l'odore della madre che lo rasserena e
che lo fa sentire bene quando lo sente e
l'ultimo messaggio che noi lasciamo
nella nostra esistenza olfattivo e
l'odore della degenerazione delle nostre
cellule
quindi dal primo all'ultimo giorno
l'olfatto fa parte della nostra vita e
dobbiamo aprire le narici del nostro
naso tutti i giorni e scoprire quali
sono le emozioni straordinarie che tutto
ciò che ci circonda ci può dare e
vediamo la grande memoria olfattiva
quella che tutti conosciamo ed è la
madeleine di proust
allora questa sera siamo veramente
tantissimi martina ci aiuta in questa in
questa cosa io ho preparato delle
magliette sono tante le profumazioni che
sentiremo questa sera vi chiedo di
compartir le un po con con i vostri
vicini
questo è proprio l'odore della madeleine
di proust
leggiamo insieme il sapore era quello
del pezzetto di mad men
quando andava a dirle bongiorno alla zia
leoni nella sua camera da letto le
adesioni mi offriva dopo averlo intinto
nel suo info
dite al tiglio quindi c'è questa madlen
questo biscotto tipicamente francese
abbinato all'infuso dite al figlio e noi
sentiamo queste due note abbinate
insieme in questo profumo che proprio ci
fanno capire quale fosse questa
profumazione che così tanto ha fatto
parlare di madlen di ricordi dal re
church di proust e adesso avrei bisogno
del secondo profumo che quello della
madame bovary dal libro appunto di
flaubert che dice andava quando charles
usciva lei andava sovente a prendere
nell'armadio fra lepre pieghe della
biancheria dove l'aveva nascosto il
portasigari di seta verde lo guardava lo
apriva giungeva ad annusare la fodera
odorosa insieme di verbena e tabacco a
chi apparteneva al visconte allora qui
flaubert
intanto ha capito che nella profumeria
ci sono le note e gli accordi e ha
utilizzato un accordo unico verbena e
tabacco per ricordare una persona per
quale motivo il visconte era così
particolare da essere ricordato proprio
anche per il suo profumo proprio perché
era un accordo unico che ha creato
flaubert di verbena e tabacco se voi
rileggendo questa pagina avrete modo di
ri annusare questa profumazione vi
renderete conto dell'importanza
fondamentale di questa descrizione che
non è solo visiva è una descrizione
olfattiva e proprio per questo come
abbiamo visto molto più incisiva molto
più profonda
ecco grazie e questa è un'altra emozione
fortissima che noi non conosciamo ma
conoscono molto bene le persone che
hanno fatto l'esperienza della seconda
guerra mondiale a londra a londra
tutte le persone si rifugiavano proprio
nel tunnel delle metropolitane e oltre
ad esserci tantissime persone spesso
venivano accatastati anche i corpi dei
morti e quindi per disinfettare e
eliminare questo odore molto forte della
guerra era l'odore tipico della guerra
gli inglesi vaporizza vano la lavanda
proprio perché era un odore familiare
quindi rassicurante per loro ma
soprattutto era un disinfettante allora
per noi la lavanda che è un odore di
pulito di pulizia per loro invece è
l'odore della guerra e vediamo una nota
straordinaria bene voglio parlare perché
questa è la rosa di tai taif è un
piccolo paese dell'arabia saudita dove
di giorno ci sono più di 50 gradi di
notte meno di 20
e questa rosa che sentirete molto molto
più intensa viene coltivata ed estratta
esclusivamente con acqua e fuoco per
distillazione se ne ottengono 16 chili
all'anno e costa più di 55mila euro al
chilo il re dell'arabia saudita lo
divide in piccoli flaconcini da un
grammo che si chiamano tola e lo regala
ai dignitari che hanno fatto qualcosa di
molto importante per lui quindi trovarsi
di fronte ad un uomo che a questo odore
significa in arabia saudita essere di
fronte a qualcuno che ha veramente
una grande importanza presso il re
quindi questo profumo il profumo della
memoria di grande prestigio
teniamo presente che i sauditi sono i
più grandi consumatori al mondo di
profumi quindi il profumo veramente
assume una caratteristica di grande
prestigio in questo caso e vediamo un
lavoro straordinario che ho per me ma al
quale sono molto legata che il profumo
del quadro di caravaggio per il
suonatore di liuto per il museo ermitage
di san pietroburgo possiamo dare la
profumazione questo profumo fu
commissionato da giustiniani per
rappresentare i cinque sensi
caravaggio lo realizzò proprio come
vediamo con questa caraffa di fiori che
rappresentano il fatto i frutti per il
gusto
il tatto perché il suonatore suona il
liuto la vista perché il suonatore
guarda tutti coloro che lo ammirano e
l'udito perché il madrigale replicabile
quindi io con un lavoro di estrazione
filologica degli elementi del quadro o
dapprima estratto tutti i fiori poi
frutti e poi per esempio il profumo di
cera che voi potete sentire che quello
che era presente sul sul tavolo il
tavolo come vedete era di marmo di finto
marmo dipinto quindi sopra questa
lavorazione veniva protette questa
lavorazione veniva protetta con della
cera che noi sentiamo questo lavoro
quindi è stato esposto al museo mytouch
proprio di fronte al quadro per ammirare
questo dipinto e sentirne gli odori che
caravaggio stesso sentiva perché noi
caravaggio sappiamo che dipingeva dal
tipo e quindi selezionava lui stesso
ogni singolo elemento questo quindi è il
profumo della memoria di un grandissimo
quadro ed infine siamo qui a sentire un
profumo che tutti noi conosciamo e che
luchino visconti volle nella scena
straordinaria del ballo del gattopardo
tutti gli dissero luchino mai nessuno
sentirà questo profumo vedendo le
immagini ma lui disse no assolutamente
la cardinale deve essere vera la vera
angelica e quindi avere il profumo che
veramente si sentiva in tutte le case
della sicilia in quell'epoca
partiamo con le immagini e sentiamo
questo straordinario profumo che parla
della nostra terra che parla di un
un'opera cinematografica straordinaria e
ci fa ricordare che l'italia è un paese
straordinario di grandissima creatività
e di grande e profumi grazie ancora
[Musica]
base nemmeno mi fossi messo d'accordo
con l'oltre strategia non è tanto come
rimbalzi o forse sì agiate in tutto ma
non ho certo ti prego scusami
[Musica]
sono tutti gentili con me e io sono
felici e contanti tancredi e proprio in
amore e anche lei un amore lo smak meno
male che tancredi non sente quello che
vi dico davvero si so di dovere tutto ma
anche tanta nel io devo perché se lei
non avesse voluto certamente timica
teneva che dan credit avrebbe sposato la
stessa ridotta a testona malevoli e vera
gioia
[Musica]
[Applauso]